rennes et non pas la crimée un
territoire annexé par la russie
l'ukraine continue donc a montré ses
capacités de résistance dans le sud de
son territoire oui visiblement il ya une
vraie stratégie qui en place depuis déjà
plusieurs semaines de la part des
ukrainiens leurs calculs en fait c'est
de dire bon ça reste très compliquée à
l'est mais en même temps c'est à l'est
que les russes concentre l'essentiel de
leurs troupes donc nous on va tenter de
percer vers le sud est de reprendre déjà
carson qui a été il faut le rappeler la
première ville qui avait été prise par
les russes donc symboliquement si les
ukrainiens parvenait à reprendre
personnes ce serait une très belle
victoire d'autant plus que le temps
presse si j'ose dire puisque on sait que
les russes veulent qu'ils organisaient
un référendum qui déciderait en fait
l'arrimage un peu définitifs deux
personnes à la russie donc il faut aller
vite l'automne 1 n'est pas très loin
autant de facteurs qui font que les
ukrainiens accentue un peu leur pression
sur carson avec un certain effet
visiblement comme le disait notre envoyé
spécial mélanie huet il y à une heure
chez vous raphaël
visiblement il ya une nervosité à
l'intérieur de la ville de la part des
autorités russes ensuite il y a
effectivement ces dépôts de munitions
qui expose pour la deuxième fois en
crimée alors toute la question c'est de
savoir d'abord qui a fait sauter ses
dépôts de munitions brrr une des
possibilités évidemment c'est que c'est
ça a été atteint par des drones ou des
canons ukrainiens ou alors qu'il y ait
eu des éléments ukrainien infiltrée à
l'intérieur de la crise mais on ne sait
pas exactement en tout cas ça montre
aussi que les ukrainiens intègre la
crimée dans leur stratégie d'une part en
visant les dépôts de munitions pour
empêcher les russes d'alimenter leurs
troupes qui se trouvent dans le sud de
l'ukraine d'autre part pour marquer
aussi que pour les ukrainiens la crimée
doit rester en ukraine qu'elle est
occupée depuis 2014 on sait que
certaines sources occidentales à un
moment avait dit ben on pourrait
peut-être négocier avec poutine le
dombass la crimée reste à la russie et
puis on s'arrête là les ukrainiens ne
sont pas du tout sur cette ligne affaire
de souveraineté aussi on le voit bien
vladimir poutine wii voit derrière la
résistance ukrainien d'une manoeuvre des
états unis pour déstabiliser la région
et quitter
la situation en ukraine montre que les
états unis cherchent à faire traîner ce
conflit et ils agissent de la même
manière en instiguant des potentiels
conflits en asie en afrique et en
amérique latine
le président russe bruno et ce n'est pas
un hasard à qui faites au passage de
l'analogie avec taïwan oui parce qu'en
fait vladimir poutine il essaye de
convaincre les pays soient qui sont
neutres soit qu'ils sont plutôt à ses
côtés des biens de renforcer cette
alliance anti occidental donc là il est
dans une visée un peu géopolitique si
vous voulez de dire contrairement à ce
que disent les occidentaux ce n'est pas
nous qui selon le le chaos et le
désordre en europe nous réagissons à une
situation agressive créé par les états
unis et leurs alliés
c'est l'otan en europe qu'ils nous ont
obligés de d'agir sur l'ukraine sinon
l'ukraine allait basculer dans le dans
le camp occidental et donc il est temps
effectivement cette analyse à d'autres
régions du monde notamment en asie en
parlant donc deux blocs
politico-militaire agressif sur les
termes du président russe qui sont
encouragés par les états unis notamment
effectivement dans la zone indo
pacifique donc là c'est un clin d'oeil à
peu appuyé à la chine vous avez parlé
effectivement de taiwan là aussi c'est
la même logique un peu inversée de celle
des occidentaux qui est à l'oeuvre c'est
de dire non non ce ne sont pas les
chinois qui sont responsables de la
tension actuelle à taïwan ce sont les
visées américaines et les provocations
et il cite évidemment la visite de nancy
pelosi récemment suivi quelques jours
plus tard deux représentants américains
le président russe parle de provocation
minutieusement planifié donc le message
c'est en gros nous menons le même combat
avec les chinois notamment contre
l'impérialisme occidental merci bruno